bref vous mettre aussi en isoler un
loyer à quoi ressemblera le futur verger
participatif de la sourderie c'était
l'objectif du premier atelier auquel ont
participé une quarantaine d'habitants
des communes de voisins-le-bretonneux et
montigny le bretonneux qui peut amener
aussi de la biodiversité des oiseaux des
insectes voilà remettre de la vie en
fait dans une zone qui apparemment
actuellement n'est que non une vulgaire
pelouse quoi on a travaillé sur plus
l'organisation le comment ça va se
mettre en place la gouvernance
les aspects plus pratiques et les
valeurs qu'on souhaite transmettre dans
ce dans ces rejets c'est une parcelle de
5000 mètres carrés au bord du plan d'eau
qui a été retenu à l'issue de cet
atelier les idées vont être compilées
par un paysagiste et d expert en
arboriculture
les participants sont accompagnés de
plusieurs associations comme ce qui en
transition ce qui pousse et vergers
urbain on va pas juste plainte et rejet
après on s'arrête là on a du suivi et de
l'accompagnement donc des formations au
cours de la nes 2022 sur la taille de
formation d un fruitier sur la greffe
matière sur les différents
thèmes de la biodiversité au verger etc
les premières plantations sont prévues
au printemps prochain ce projet entre
dans le cadre du plan climat et du
développement de l'agriculture locale et
des circuits courts de l'agglomération
adopté en 2019 dans
l'agriculture urbaine pour ce
développement on a repéré 11 secteur
dans les 12 communes de l'agglomération
sur lesquels il nous semble possible de
faire ses premiers développements un
écho pâturages va aussi bientôt voir le
jour sur le même espace les moutons sont
attendus le 22 octobre prochain un
deuxième secteur des ponts développement
leval favery à coignières